[Music]
on today's show we're going to talk
about a fear of failure during a job
transition
we're going to talk to an exhausted
mother of four who needs her husband to
step
up and we're going to talk about what
happens
when someone you love did things in the
past
that are affecting you in the present
stay tuned
[Music]
[Applause]
what's up i'm john and this is the dr
john deloney show where we take your
calls about
your life the things going on in your
world
in your hearts in your minds we're
talking about relationships
your relational iq mental health your
physical health
marriage we might even talk about people
who continue to take zoom meetings from
their bed
we just as a group need to just say
we're done with that
it's weird it makes me uncomfortable and
it's hard to make me uncomfortable i'm
just a guy that doesn't have discomfort
but when i'm
in a zoom meeting and timmy pops up
in the washing machine room because
that's where he's converted an office i
think
good job man washing machine room that's
not even a thing 1842
the laundry room and timmy shows up in
the laundry room
where he's made a converted office i
think he's awesome i was like way to go
dude that's
that's pretty cool and then you know
ken shows up in his kid his kids room
and
that's where they're they're meeting i
think way to go man
and then james shows up in bed in bed
like he just pops up on the screen and
he's got pillows around and a weird
ratty graphic tee and a sideways hat
and he's like hey guys ready for the
meeting and i just think that's just
weird
it's gross just i don't i just don't
need those things in my head
and so let's just all as a team say
we're not going to do zoom meetings from
beds anymore
we're not gonna do church services from
beds that's happening
sunday school teachers don't teach from
your bed um
i don't know yoga instructors go to the
outside go to the garage whatever let's
just get out of our beds and zoom calls
and we're gonna talk about that and more
on the show
we're going to be talking about anything
and everything in your heart and your
mind of the universe
so give me a call 1-844-693-3291
that's 1-844-693-3291
or you can always email me at ask john
ramseysolutions.com
that's ask john ramseysolutions.com the
emails are
flowing in and they are coming from all
over the world literally
super cool so glad to be connecting with
everybody thank you so much let's just
go straight to it let's go to kara
in bellevue washington cara good morning
how are you
good morning dr d i'm great how are you
good good good
how can i help you this morning i am
having a
uh for the first time in my life a
little career
dilemma i need some advice on all right
bring it on what's going on
so i've been at the same company i've
been in the
dental field for about 13 years now with
the same
practice for the full 13 years are you a
dentist or a
dental hygienist what are you doing
there um i was a
dental assistant now i'm kind of like a
patient care coordinator office manager
type position
very cool and just as an aside you see
some crazy stuff in a dentist office
don't you
yes we do i always think that a dentist
like
i don't know like a dentist and a
proctologist those two
know like i can tell you about yourself
right
like everyone else can be lied to but
y'all those two doctors
y'all i mean you get to see it all so
man
god bless you man i yeah that's a whole
other conversation about dental hygiene
but all right so go
go ahead you're thinking about changing
changing plans
yes i um i'm at the point so my husband
and i just became debt free
um congratulations awesome
thank you and i'm wanting to change
professions
um i
have never changed the profession before
this is my whole working career and i've
been with the same doctor and i'm just
i have a you can almost call it a
crippling fear of failure
and disappointing people so i just don't
really know
how to go about the transition without
disappointing pretty much everybody
involved
when's the last time you super super
failed at something like you just
rocket diarrhea everywhere in a big box
of farts when's the last time you did
that
honestly i don't remember exactly when's
the last time you were in a situation
where you just
mass disappointed everyone in your
sphere
probably never probably so what is it
about this transition that
suddenly makes those things that have
never happened before
they're not a part of you at all that
they're going to suddenly happen this
time
probably because there's more people
involved
you know i have a husband and a
two-year-old daughter
and you know you just kind of feel like
people are
not wanting you to fail but you just
kind of because you haven't had such a
big failure in life i feel like it's
i'm doomed for it i'll say it all right
so i'm waiting for life to just hit me
right in the head
yes the nerd word for that is
catastrophizing
oh great it's this sense of i've had my
good run
and life is a mix of good stuff and bad
stuff
so i've had a good job my husband and i
love each other
we've worked really hard to accomplish
this mega goal which is to be debt free
i've got a beautiful two-year-old who is
healthy
and fat and fun and
mushy and huggy so any day now
somebody's getting cancer
any day now the car wheels are going to
fall off while we're driving and we're
going to go head over heels into the
whatever right that's just this looming
sense and then when you decide to be the
one who
pulls the trigger metaphorically right
you're the one who decides
i'm just going to leave this profession
i'm tired of digging into people's faces
it's it's grossing me out nobody flosses
they all lie to me and if everyone keeps
drinking all these
drinks with sugar in them their teeth
are gonna fall out of their fa
you're just sick of it and now you're
gonna build a story that makes you
the reason your family falls apart
everybody fails and everyone's
disappointed in you right
100 okay so what i want you to do
is two things number one i want you to
stay on the line kelly daniels going to
give you my friend ken coleman's book
the proximity principle
it's a it's a not a huge book it's a
short book but it is just a couple of
key steps on what to do when you're
thinking of making a major transition
okay
um and he's a buddy of mine he lives in
that
um how to find work that
makes your heart full and passionate
world that's his that's his universe
the second thing is i'm just going to
tell you what just happened with me i
spent
most of my professional career working
up to a place where i was going to be a
senior leader at a college
at a fancy college and i accomplished
that
and it was all the colleges i worked at
were excellent
the people i worked with were awesome at
all of those colleges
i learned awesome things and i finally
quote unquote made it
i got to where i was going to get and
then one day i gave a speech and dave
ramsey's executive vice president
sat in that audience she was dropping
her child off
and she said i'm gonna hire that guy and
that started
a 18-month courting process and
i quit every single thing i know
to come sit in this room right here and
talk to some cameras and to talk to
people
across the country that i'll probably
never meet in person
and it was a radical departure i'm a
dude who did not want to be on the
internet i didn't want to
um i didn't want to be a public i just
had no desire
for that i wanted to just stay at a
small little college and take care of my
students and their families
and to occasionally work with crisis
folks outside
and so i want to tell you this is this
terrifying to make this move
yep i just did it is it um
could it go catastrophically wrong for
sure
for sure it could right cara could it
you're doing good so far okay but here's
the thing
if i look around my life and find out
the last time i catastrophically failed
except for this thing i did at battle
the bands the other day it was dreadful
i totally screwed up this band's
performance i did get up in front of a
couple like
one or two thousand people and mess up
bad i did do that but what i'm talking
about like professionally
that i just really just burned the house
down it hasn't happened yet
and it hasn't happened with you either
so i want you to look at
the your past performance your past
history as a good predictor of what's
going to happen next
okay what you are dealing with is a
natural thing called resistance it's
it's
brilliantly outlined in steven
pressfield's book
um the war of art you should probably
grab that book it's really small
it is remarkable stephen pressfield the
war of art
but it talks about it personifies this
resistance this thing that emerges this
shadowy
ghostly figure that emerges anytime we
want to make major life change
we want to make major life change
and push forward and do things that are
different
and then resistance shows up and blocks
us it blames us
it says oh you're probably gonna fail
you should probably just stay stagnant
and keep doing what you're doing
and it gives you some good strategies
for pushing through it at the end of the
day
cara i think you're going to do awesome
i think you should jump
i think you should follow ken's steps of
getting with the right people making
sure you know where you're going
don't jump too soon before you have
another boat in the harbor right
otherwise you're just going to be
treading water for a while
get a good game plan for where you want
to go but man i say go for it
i say absolutely go for it you've put
yourself in a position financially
i want your daughter or your son your
two-year-old to grow up
in a home where mom is totally fulfilled
where she is joyful where her
she laughs loud where she loves
her husband and her kids recklessly
and that she every day she goes to work
um
with a sense of purpose um a sense of
you know of passion um
all of it that's that's what i want for
your kids that's what i want for your
husband so
um yeah go for it cara hey call me back
when you do it call me back when you
when you quit and you go to the next
thing call me back and let me know
all right let's go to the next call
let's go to kerry in lubbock texas
carrie how in the world are you
doing good dr daloni how are you i am
having a blast today
so number one how is my old stomping
grounds is things going okay in lubbock
texas
it's windy and cold it sounds like
business as usual
all right so how can i help you this
morning um me and my husband have been
married for
20 years okay there's no communication
about our finances
and i'm just feeling very lost and don't
know what to do
all right so
my guess is if there's no communication
about finances there's no communication
about much other than
college football is that probably fair
um stock show animals
fair fair for those of y'all not from
west texas we're having some
playing some insider baseball here um
when's the last time y'all had a good
values-based conversation
about where your marriage was going
about kids about who you guys wanted to
be when you grew up
when's the last time you had that
conversation or have you ever
we haven't ever he won't
sit down and talk to me and the other
day i asked him
he wanted to do something and i said you
know what i want to do i want to sit
down and have a real conversation about
our finances and what we need to do we
just recently sold our home
and we moved back up here to where he's
from in
lubbock and we have this big dream of
building a house and trying to get
everything together
and he tells me he's busy
he doesn't have time and so what is it
about having a conversation that scares
him
i'm not sure i'm not sure and
so let me ask you a harder question what
is it about having a conversation with
you that scares him
and i feel like
he maybe thinks he's failed um out of
the 20 years we've been married
he's only worked eight of those okay
i have my own business and he he has
helped me
but um when we first got married he
worked
all the time when i was going to college
and we had our first daughter
and um then it's like he just quit
and he comes to me and he
he he wants something and i'll tell him
no we can't afford that and he gets
upset and mad at me
and tells me i just need to work harder
okay
and then what does he do on on the days
that you're at work did you sit at home
yes does he always have a scheme a plan
i'm just waiting on this phone call to
come in or
this is going to happen soon is it that
kind of situation
no um he's recently started
working and
so he has been going to work for the
last week
and he's hoping it becomes something
good
i've always been the breadwinner in the
family
um but like my mother-in-law who lives
right next to us
told my daughter when she came down from
college this weekend that
um i made enough money and that my
husband just needed to
stay at home and watch the boys okay is
that an arrangement
you all have that happens all over the
country but usually it's something that
people plan together it doesn't just
inorganically happen or do you not want
to work anymore
um well i mean i'm i'm tired
i do i do a lot i've had my own business
for 15 years
we have four children i do everything
with their
education because he he he was not very
good in school
and but common sense wise i mean he's a
good old farm boy
and he is really good at outside things
and but everything else i do and
so it's just it's just starting to wear
on me after 15 years of doing that
um completely basically on my own and i
just
you know i just wish that he would sit
down and talk to me about things instead
of telling me he's busy
or he's got he basically just doesn't
want to carry can i challenge you on
something
i think you've been tired for a long
long time
i think you've been exhausted for a long
long time
and so what i want to know from you is
why now
because you would have been exhausted
i've got two kids and i've got a
wife who is an absolute gangster rock
star and i'm tired
you know what i mean four plus a
full-time gig
plus a husband who's part child too
you've been tired for a long long time
um what has kept you from having that
conversation
for five years ten years
just the fact that i guess i feel
a lot of myself feels ashamed of me
because i feel like i have failed what
did you fail carrie
like our our love for each other is
great but our relationship is not
what does that even mean
um but every morning he tells me he
loves me
and i say i love you too and at night
always say i love you
but we have no communication and can't
talk to each other about things
well yeah but i i could wake up i could
wake up with my wife every morning and
say
honey i'm a dragon and she could say i'm
a carton of milk
and that wouldn't make either of those
things real right and so
just going through the motions and
repeating the words doesn't mean much
anything um
i feel like i get mad and angry yeah
you should get mad and angry you should
be frustrated okay
i do you should be and here's what anger
is
all anger is is a it is a signal
pointing you towards something that you
care about anger is a good thing
anger lets you know i really care about
this guy
and i need him to go work i need him to
go be a provider for this family or
i need him to be a full-time
stay-at-home dad and take some of this
relational burden off me some of the
cooking and cleaning and
the ceo of the house roll from me i
desperately need some help
and some of that's about him needing to
grow up
and some of that quite honestly is
i'm going to guess is part of the
greater plague on men across the country
which is
they don't know what to do anymore
especially guys who work outside
who have been told working outside is
for idiots for second-rate losers
that work is getting harder and harder
to come by as the farms get bought up
and as
water gets more and more scarce the
whole industry is turning over
and there's a whole swath of guys who
don't know what to do next
and and then there's equally a swath of
women caught right in the middle of that
mess
and so my dream and hope for you carrie
is that he would be able to come in and
sit with you
and say listen since i was about
six i've been posturing i've been
playing and i'm exhausted and i want to
love my wife the right way
and i don't know how can we go learn how
to do this together
i love how esther perel says most adults
have three or four great loves in their
life
and if people work really hard and if
they're lucky it's with the same person
and i believe he can come around but i
also believe he's not going to be the
one who
who has that conversation first
right what i want you to do is to
go spend some time gathering your
thoughts
with probably with a counselor by this
point 15 years of this
is relatively traumatic it's not
relatively
15 years of this is traumatic it's
exhausting
and it's heartbreaking but i believe you
that you still love this dude and i
believe you that when you tell me he's
still worth it
but this is a conversation you gotta
have now because here's why
you got four kids you're modeling this
for
you guys they see it that's right and
more than they see it
carry they feel it yep
they actually come to me and they're
like mom it's okay yeah
and here's the deal you know kids have
no business trying to make sure their
parents are okay
that's not their job right right
it's not their job at the end of the day
all you can control is you
and whether that's by modeling what this
is going to look like which is
honey i'm going to start seeing a
counselor now i would love for you to
come with me
there are some awesome counselors and
marriage therapists in lubbock texas i
know him personally that's where i was
trained
there are some extraordinary people
there in that community that can walk
alongside you
and they can walk alongside your husband
but it's also about you not waiting
until you're exhausted and frustrated
and fed up before you go have that
conversation
because the worst thing you can do to a
guy that's feeling beaten down the guy
that's feeling like he's failed for 10
years
is to run at him when you're angry but
to have a safe place where y'all can
have a good conversation
and here's the other deal carrie the
reality is some guys never get it
some wives never get it either and i
think the hard part for you right now is
you recognize that maybe you
it may never come together for you
but all of the wishing and the idol
knows and the imaginary conversations
you have in your head with him
that never happen in real life the
things that you think that he's not
doing these things because of
all of those things are poisoning you
and weighing you down
and they're starting to leak out on your
kids
so can i get a commitment from you that
beginning today you're going to start
taking care of yourself that you'll go
through
and find someone to talk to today make
an appointment today before the day's
over
yes okay and i want you to tell him
your husband i love you and we're gonna
schedule a meeting
just a state of the union how's our
marriage how's our kids
how's our future we're gonna schedule a
meeting and i want you to plan it for a
week in advance or two weeks in advance
and there are some cooler breakfast
places in lubbock texas
and i want you to plan it for a place
where y'all can get up on a saturday
morning
and go talk to one another and i want
you to have a list of things written out
and i want you to make sure he knows
he's loved i want you to make sure that
he knows
that he's valued but i also want him to
know that you're exhausted
and that you are interested in
completely rebuilding your relationship
from the floor up but it's going to take
his full participation in that
and guys if you're listening to this it
is never too late
to go talk to your wife
it is never too late to go talk to your
girlfriend to someone you're interested
in to any significant other to your
parents to your friends it's never too
late guys
to go in there and say
it's been five years it's been 10 years
and i don't like the direct trajectory
of where i'm going
i don't like it i want to start over can
we rebuild this thing up from the floor
up and i'm going to need some
lessons i'm gonna need to learn how to
do this i don't even know what i feel
anymore
i'm gonna need to go back to community
college i'm gonna need to go
fill in the blanks guys it's never too
late to have that conversation
women it's never too late to have that
conversation either
you don't need to wait till new year's
eve you can start today
start today but set up some time to go
have that conversation and start taking
care of you
carrie after that conversation i want
you to call me back i want you to let me
know how it goes
and if you need some some folks in that
area that i trust
um get with kelly and then i will
connect you to somebody that
some folks that i know and love and
trust there in that community we'll be
thinking about you carrie
and um get to work on you get to work on
you
and get to work on that marriage all
right appreciate you let's go to one
more call let's go to tia in
phoenix arizona tia how we doing this
morning
good dr d thanks for taking my call
thank you so much for calling in how can
i help
um i'm really struggling with trying to
maintain a relationship with my dad
okay uh one second back up and talk
directly into the phone there
how's that ah perfect excellent all
right go for it
i'm really struggling with trying to
have a relationship with my dad
uh we just bicker constantly over
any and everything and i really struggle
with liking him i love him because he's
my dad
and i just want to know how what i can
do to be a better daughter i guess and
to make the relationship
work when there's so much conflict why
is there conflict
where's this where's the stem from so
my dad my parents were married for 25
years and my dad had
affairs throughout that entire time
the latest affair he had was while my
mom was going through breast cancer
and then 15 years later my dad has
married this woman
and so i just struggle with his life
choices i'm sure
he really struggles with the decisions
that he's made and
i guess who he is as a man but i but i
do want to have a relationship with him
why do you want a relationship with him
why do you want a relationship with a
guy that you disagree with
when it comes to values that hurt your
mom over the
quarter of a century and then
you feel like rubbed your nose in it by
mirroring the woman that he was
with while your mom was going through
breast cancer surgery
like what what about that guy do you
want a relationship with
well i guess because my my little
brother died my only sibling about a
year and a half ago
and i just don't want to lose that
because it's among family yeah
that if i don't have a relationship with
my dad that's one more person i'd be
losing
yeah i'm sorry about your brother
thank you that shouldn't happen i hate
that for you tia i'm sorry
thank you is your mom still around oh
yes
i talked to my mom 10 times a day my
mom's great what does she think about
this
this about your old man about this
ex-husband of hers
um you know she is still friends with
him like
they maintain a very healthy
relationship i guess
uh for the sake of my brother's kids
their grandkids and so my mom doesn't
like
talk down about him she understands
where i'm coming from she understands
why i'm hurt
but she doesn't she tells me i need to
do what's best for me
so she doesn't kind of like advise me to
go one way or another when it comes to
my dad
so your your oh let me ask you one more
question has your dad
ever violated your boundaries has he
been ugly to you has even supportive
of you forget what he did to your mom
has he been a good dad
financially yes emotionally i would say
no
has he hurt you financially or just not
shown up
so financially he's been great uh yeah
but financially man that that ends up
being
people wallpaper with that i mean that's
right i mean that's that's just like
fancy twizzlers for grownups people who
just throw money at problems
um yeah has he what i'm saying
emotionally is he
abusive to you does he tell you you're a
piece of crap and why'd you do that
or is he just not shown up throughout
your life i would say a little bit of
both
okay and so have you ever talked to him
about how he makes you feel
how you feel about his new wife how you
feel about what he did to your mom for
25 years
have you ever had that conversation or
does it just leak out in
and he complains to you and you complain
back and this little death by bb gun
situation
a little bit of both but when i've had
when i've tried to
uh address the issues like i'll bring up
the infidelities he'll say that those
aren't those aren't my issues that
my those are my mom's issues and they
have nothing to do with me so he'll shut
that
conversation down you know that's a
gigantic wooden box of dog crap right
yes absolutely okay that's 100
not accurate right
i i do know that because i watched it
happen my whole childhood
i was directly affected so
i'm gonna give you you called me so i'm
gonna be real honest with you okay
and then i'll give you the first thing
that popped into my head
um at some point you're gonna have to
how old are you 39 39
okay exhale real quick
big exhale can feel your shoulders tense
through the phone
all the way here in nashville good
enough okay now listen
at some point you're gonna have to let
the fantasy go
your dad sucks okay
that does not mean he's not worthy of a
relationship
that doesn't mean that he's not somebody
that um
should be in your life
but the your dream of having this
perfect dad
is not real and you got to let it go
because it's wearing you out not him
okay it's exhausting you it's keeping
that
low level hum of anxiety in your heart
all
the time and
after 39 years of this it's becoming if
it hasn't already
it's starting to depress the way you see
the world the way you interact with
people that you love
you're constantly having a minute
constantly having imaginary
conversations in your head
to him right that are never gonna happen
and those get you worked up and those
get you fired up and those get you all
pissed off
here's the thing your dad sucks man he
cheated on your mom for a quarter
century
when he needed her most he wasn't there
the thing you have in your corner is an
absolute rock star ninja mom
and here's what she's given you she's
given you a model
of i'm not gonna let somebody else's
poison kill me
right now it truly is my mom
there's that old saying in a.a hating
somebody is like poisoning yourself and
hoping they die
and your mom knows that and so i'm gonna
talk good about that guy
that absolutely devastated me for a
quarter century yeah
they broke up our family yeah
because at the end of the day your mom's
been through enough
she's not gonna let him to continue to
do that to her right
and so the earlier you can i mean the
faster you can get to a place where this
is who my dad is he doesn't tell the
truth
he's deceitful he's not honest he hurts
people around him that's just who he is
once you get to that in your heart
and you stop asking him to be something
that he's never going to be
then you can approach him on his turf
then you can make honest decisions and
assessments about do you want him around
your kids
do you want him around your
relationships do you want to be in his
life
when and how and so the one thing that
popped into my mind as you were saying
this was
at some point it'll probably do you good
to approach him like an adult and
um and that's not a slide at you that
came out as like i was i was clowning on
you
i'm saying to have two adults not father
daughter but two adults sit down and say
dad i want to have a relationship with
you here's my history with you
here's how i have absorbed this for the
last 40 years
but i love you because you're my dad
and i'm interested in moving forward
here's my boundaries i need you to be
there for me
i need you to be there for your
grandkids i need you to be honest with
me
i need you to stop saying the following
four or five hurtful things
i need you to do
have a mulligan i mean you can't get a
mulligan on that for crying out loud
i need you for whatever time we've got
left
to step up and my hope honestly
is that he will fall over on the
whatever table y'all are eating it and
he will weep and say i'm sorry will you
forgive
me he's probably not going to
and so i would be prepared to go into
that meeting ready to forgive him and
look him in the eye and say dad i
forgive you
because i'm not carrying your weight
anymore i'm not
i forgive you but i'd love you to be in
my life
under my terms inside of my boundaries
and if you're willing i'd love to have
you and then listen you do have a small
family
your brother unfortunately passed away i
recognize that you don't want to lose
somebody else
but recognize that hanging on to
somebody else sometimes means you're
going to drown
and like the the stewardess on the
airline says you got to put on your
oxygen mask first or everyone around you
goes down
everyone around you goes down so tia
let me know how that conversation goes
with him if you decide to have it
but you're going to have to put the
fantasy down your dad is who he is
and any amount of wishing and begging
and yelling and fighting isn't gonna
change him at this point
just put it down thank you so so much
for that call to you
all right so as we transition out it's
been a heavy
calls today man so we transition out i
want to thank everybody for sticking
with us and continue to listen
for continuing to join us on the show
oh man i'm glad we're ending on this
song
this is the greatest song ever written
this is a shout out to
my boyhood friends chris and ryan and
caleb
song that we used to listen to when we
were little kids
and we'd always dream of whoever she was
gonna be whenever she was gonna be
wherever she showed up it was a song
written
by five dudes who are pretty awesome and
a band called skid row
was released in november of 1989 as the
third single
from their debut record the song is i
remember you
and it goes like this i woke up to the
sound of pouring rain
the wind would whisper and i'd think of
you and all the tears you cried that
called my name
and when you needed me i came through
oh my darling i love you i remember
yesterday walking hand in hand
love letters in the sand i remember you
through the sleepless nights through
every endless day
i'd want to hear you say i remember you
what a song pines guys what a song this
is the dr john daloni show